it is great to be joined today by Ella
al Shama he who is a National Geographic
Explorer Neanderthal specialist in cave
and unstable territories and stand-up
comic Ella it's so great to talk to you
I was first sort of more interested in
learning about Neanderthals when I got
my DNA test results and it said I had
you know I was in the 55th percentile or
something
in terms of Neanderthal DNA and I didn't
fully even really understand what that
meant and I started reading more about
what is the history of Neanderthals in
the context of Homo Sapien so maybe
let's start there I mean for the average
person who is watching and is a member
of the of the human species which is
most of the people in the audience
although if you saw my inbox you might
question some of that what is important
to know now about the sort of history
and relationship of Neanderthals to
modern humans so I suppose the first
point is that when you say human species
the truth is there's a number of human
species or at least there was and that's
because this is the only time in human
history where only one species of homo
has walked this earth which is kind of
cool because you know once upon a time
it was essentially a Lord of the Rings
scenario and there was a whole pile of
different species of human so there's a
homo sapiens and then another one
probably the most famous is Homo
neanderthalensis and it's such a
mouthful there everyone just says in the
ad with all
so the Ansel's are our cousins and what
happened was they left Africa before we
did they evolved into Neanderthals and
then when we left Africa we bumped into
them again and so the question for a
really long time was what happened when
we bumped into them you know did we bump
into them and when we bumped into them
was it make love not war or was it for
not you know whatever and it turned out
we don't really know the full story but
what we know for sure is that there was
there was some loving yeah so correct me
if I'm wrong but for some time it seemed
that though the predominant point of
view was that there was no mixing at all
between what we would now consider
modern whoo
and Neanderthals it is that true was it
that cut-and-dry at some point and what
happened to change that so that was the
dominant view that was definitely the
dominant view was it was definitely seen
a massive debate in in penny or
anthropology but it was pretty much the
dominant view that you know we didn't
really interact with them and we
certainly didn't have you know anything
other you know there was no middling as
such but it turned out that there was
and the way that we found that out was
actually just quite incredible it's
actually ancient DNA so for a really
long time our field was essentially
digging into the ground and bringing up
bones right and then they managed to
extract DNA from these really really old
fossils and it was a revolution it
completely revolutionized our field and
and when they looked at this ancient DNA
they were able to see that actually you
know what yeah there were a number of
interactions there and so essentially
everyone outside of sub-saharan Africa
has some Neanderthal ancestry because at
some point our ancestors basically
having sex with Neanderthals
so I know that that's where yes yes
which we will get to I know that our
language abilities were significantly
superior to Neanderthals but and I know
we we may not have a definitive answer
to this what do we suspect about what
our ability to communicate would have
been with Neanderthals I mean if you
imagine sort of like a spectrum where on
one side you know we try to communicate
with a parakeet and it's extraordinarily
difficult versus like someone you
disagree with politically where it might
just be sort of ideological
disagreements do we have a sense of
where on that spectrum our communication
with and earth all's would have been so
I think it's probably important to
actually say that I mean you're right we
don't we know it's hard when something's
been dead for so long you know they've
been gone for forty thousand years right
so it's really hard to work out what was
happening there with language
and I have to say when I first started
studying Neanderthals there was a debate
as to whether they had language at all
whether they spoke at all now I think
the consensus is pretty much that they
had language the debate is whether they
had a proto language something that you
know isn't as advanced as ours or if it
was a bit more advanced than that that I
think that's more where the debate is
and it's really difficult to work that
out so genetically there are some
indicators that they they had language
but possibly we were able to do
something called we're able to do
something they they can't but it's
really difficult because it's still
early days with some of the genetic
stuff but beyond that you you look at
the way that they lived so you look at
the way that they were able to express
themselves through art through culture
through their hunting methods and you
look at that honey how did you do that
if you didn't at least have a proto
language so it's it's difficult but then
you've got to think as well the truth is
Homo sapiens probably didn't have well
you know the language that we have right
now is the result of probably cumulative
culture this idea that every single
generation improves upon the generation
before it and so truthfully we were
probably you know our vocab was probably
limited as well back then so yeah so
it's a difficult one to work out right
but it's always fun to speculate how
that first how those first few meetings
would have gone you know with what the
Neanderthal have been seen as some
backwards type person who you could
barely communicate where they were we on
par with them it's really difficult to
tell yeah and I eventually I want to get
to the sort of like intellectual
dominance over Neanderthals but before
we do that what if if we were talking
about survival of either Neanderthals or
Homo sapiens coming down to sort of
physical abilities we would have been
significantly outmatched by the and
earth all's is that safe is that in
question at all at this point you know
what that was that was a really fun
exercise so we made this series about
Neanderthals in fact that's coming out
of Wednesday in the US on PBS and one of
the big debates we had was who would
a fight between a Neanderthal and
ourselves and it was really really
difficult and I think the consensus is
probably that it would have been you
wouldn't have wanted to meet any and
earth all down the dark alleyway because
they're definitely they're stronger than
us but there is this possibility that
because we were taller thinner kind of
able to probably bounce around a little
bit better but we might have had that
kind of it would have been an
interesting fight to watch let's just
say that the the show that comes out
Wednesday there's actually a scene where
we show in the ads all and ourselves
fighting and it's interesting to watch
because Neanderthals are really short
you know compared to ourselves I mean I
mean they were still 5 foot 5 so they're
not like tiny but but it was just that
muscle strength was just something else
you know so then when it comes to the
intellectual side I mean is it that what
is the predominant theory now as to why
ultimately Homo sapiens dominated
Neanderthals and there are no longer in
the Endor Thals and we find ourselves in
this unique situation where Homo sapiens
is the one human species on earth so I
would say that um there's this there's
such a debate about this and there's no
consensus whatsoever if you look every
single year there's a different there's
a few papers that come out by remember
one year there was a suggestion that
rabbits were the reason that
Neanderthals went extinct we ate more
rabbit than they did and I just kind of
mentioned that as an example to show how
how much we disagree in our field about
what caused their extinction i i'd say
though Neanderthals had a really really
good run so Neanderthals were around for
you know maybe 300 maybe 400 thousand
years that long so it might not actually
be a case of they died out because we
beat them at it you know it might not be
simple but they were really successful
species I think there's an argument
that's quite a lot of people kind of
take on this argument that we may have
had an advantage in terms of our
population size so we tended to have
larger groups there was more of us and
we were possibly doing something more
advanced culturally it's really
difficult though to be sure that that's
why we ended up with an edge I think
personally I'm inclined to think we were
doing something that no other species
before us was doing which was something
about our group size these these bigger
group sizes which meant that culturally
we were able to transmit knowledge in a
more interesting more radical way maybe
and that as a result our cultural
expression was more advanced but even me
saying that's really controversial some
people would really disagree with that
and say no in the Ansel's had you know
cultural expression that was really
advanced too so it's one of the big
mysteries you know why are we here and
they're not and it's not just about them
actually in so many ways it's about all
the other species that went extinct as
well as we became more and more dominant
all these other human species also
became extinct so the question is what
happened you know did was that a result
of us and it I mean if you just look at
the numbers it kind of looks like it
might you know it's we suddenly appeared
we spread out of Africa and suddenly all
these other species of human just
started to disappear what type of
advance in science would be necessary in
order for us to get more definitive
answers to some of these questions or is
it actually the opposite which is that
as more and more time elapses it will
become even more difficult to get
definitive answers to some of these
questions yeah I think some of these
answers you're never gonna find you know
you're you know like I don't know but
then then I think nobody expected there
to you know there to be this massive
ancient DNA discovery right because that
was something that completely
revolutionized our field then suddenly
you were able to say definitively yes we
interbred with them and the thing is
David like you know let's be honest like
30 40 years ago
you'd have set two penny anthropologists
or an archaeologist can you say
definitively and will you ever be able
to say definitively that we you know
interpret with them the answer would be
no we there's no definitive way of
knowing so the truth is I'm kind of
hesitant to kind of give you an answer
to that because the truth is forty years
from now somebody might discover
something that really kind of blows the
top of it but I think it's gonna be
really tough I think ancient DNA is
really interesting and the more we look
at that the more interesting it becomes
and then the more fossil finds that's
also really important and sometimes our
fossil find or an archaeological find
will really shed light on something so
there was fine there's been a number of
finds recently where people have said
like this is really good proof of what
they were able to do and it's not it's
not small these are really culturally
advanced people so yes we may not even
know the ways yet in which we would
learn things about the past when it's 50
or a hundred years from now and that is
not really impossible to know from aji
so this Wednesday American viewers can
see what what exactly should people be
watching on Wednesday so there's two
things that I think one is it so it's on
PBS and it's at 9:00 it's at 10:00 9:00
central and the the coolest thing I
think is that we managed to get the the
Hollywood king of motion-capture ie Andy
Serkis who brought us you know Gollum
Caesar King Kong he basically brings the
most scientifically accurate Neanderthal
to life and what we do is we get that
Neanderthal and we put him on the London
metro and we ask you if you would change
carriages and it's really really
interesting because when you see this
this person brought to life I think I
think people's responses will be very
very yeah very interesting as to whether
they'd really change carriages or not be
Metro in the New York City metro nobody
would even pay any attention but I've
been on the London metro and it's a much
more calm and sort of it's a different
experience where I feel like a
Neanderthals would stand out more in the
New York City metro at least the four
five train it's just like it's just
another day commuting you know yeah I
mean it's a I
element of wondering if it's just the
place that we put this poor person in
but know this it's definitely it's
definitely a really really interesting
one and then the other thing we ask is
about medical stuff because there's
there's now a lot of talk about the
medical implications of getting this DNA
from Neanderthals because it looks like
there's a number of diseases which we
have and also immunities which we've
picked up that are a direct result of
Neanderthals which is in of itself just
a new feel than just fascinating so
there's some of that as well
we have been speaking with Ella al Shama
hey check it out National Geographic
this Wednesday
ten-nine CBS PBS I'm sorry National
Geographic she is a National Geographic
Explorer the program is on PBS Ella
thank you so much for talking to us
today thanks for having me